in this video I'm going to share several
astonishing new details that have come
to light involving the topic of the Lost
ancient city of Atlantis and the eye of
the Sahara which in just the last few
years has taken the Internet by storm as
this unbelievably bizarre structure just
so happens to match a dozen of the most
significant similarities to Plato's
description of the famed lost capital
city of Atlantis but perhaps the only
thing Stranger Than these striking
comparisons is the fact that the Rishad
structure itself remains a genuine
scientific mystery that continues to
confound scientists to this day as this
one-of-a-kind geological feature is like
no other place found anywhere else on
Earth and has remained essentially
hidden and largely unknown within the
remote Western Sahara Desert of
Mauritania which only makes its
distinctive nature that much more
Curious when you consider that so few
people have still never seen or heard of
it before even even including the most
curious and inquisitive Minds around but
let me ask you this Joe real quick when
you saw my video was that the very first
time you had ever seen this thing before
yeah that's the thing and that is the
thing because if nothing else this
extraordinarily unique anomaly should be
included on the list of natural wonders
of the world but nevertheless when you
see the new lines of evidence that I'm
going to share in this video it will
become exceedingly apparent that the
fittingly named eye of the Sahara is by
far the most likely location for the
Lost capital city of Atlantis and not
only that these new details will likely
make those who previously thought that
this site could not possibly be the
location of Atlantis think again so with
all of that said let me start off by
sharing something particularly
interesting it is widely known that the
ancient Romans were renowned for
documenting everything as the Caesars
went to profound extent to accumulate
knowledge and information from every
location their vast Empire ventured so I
have to admit that I was quite surprised
to learn of someone by the name of
pomponius Maya who was the Roman's first
geographer dating back to some 2000
years ago and had created a
sophisticated map of the known world at
that time titled the habitable world of
pomponius Maya something that up until
recently I had never seen or heard of
before and real quick let's not confuse
this map with the ancient Greek
historian herodotus's map of the known
world of 2500 years ago which I shared
in one of my prior videos on this topic
a map that curiously listed Atlantis in
the same location of the rishat however
the original source of this map is a bit
of a mystery as modern historians claim
that Herodotus is not known to have ever
created an actual map and have thus put
its Origins into question so putting
that map aside let's focus on this
verifiably authentic two thousand year
old map that has also annotated
something very interesting in the
western Sahara Desert first notice that
this map is oriented to the east in its
original form so let me go ahead and
flip it to a north south facing
orientation so we can gain our bearing
and the features of Europe West Asia and
North Africa become apparent so let's
now focus our attention to what is in
the northwest region of the Sahara and
observe what it annotates here Atlantia
or atlantier which more or less appears
as atlanteans and again in the same
geographical region of the risott
structure which like I've shared in my
prior videos just so happens to
coincidentally match so many precise
details The Plato described of Atlantis
including that the capital city was
famously said to be made up of
concentric circles specifically three
rings of water and two of land which
correctly matches the wrist shot with
water in it which it certainly did is I
will prove to you with hard scientific
data in just a moment but the circular
ring city was also said to have an
opening to the Sea at the South which
not only matches the southernly opening
of the rishat anomaly but it even has
existing evidence of a flow of salt
water that is still visible to this day
which and again I will prove with hard
scientific evidence shortly but Atlantis
was also said to be surrounded by a
large rectangular plane which is another
arguable similarity that extends for
hundreds of miles on both sides of the
wrist shot but furthermore Atlantis was
said to be made of black red and white
color Stones which is another
specifically unique similarity that
matches the geological nature of the
wrist shot and speaking of uniquely
specific geological features this next
detail that I recently learned of blew
me away as there is English literature
from the year 1851 on the preliminary
treaties of resources of ancient
Mauritania which describes the country
as having gold and considerable
quantities and even specifically States
and I quote that it is a well
authenticated fact that previous to the
discovery of America Europe was supplied
to a great extent with gold from
Mauritania how have I never heard of
this before and get this Mauritania was
so rich in Gold that several hundred
years ago A King by the name of Mansa
Musa of the Mali Empire which was a
region of Africa that includes
modern-day Mauritania was said to have
been the richest man in all of human
history so rich that he far exceeds the
richest billionaires alive today in fact
he owned gold mines which account for
more than half of the world's supply of
gold today and by the way something else
you'll find interesting related to that
1851 treaties of ancient mauritanian
resources is that it describes ancient
Mauritania of having an abundance of
elephant Ivory which is a significant
detail considering that Atlantis was
said to have numerous elephants on the
island and so it's worth mentioning that
there is also existing cave art
depicting elephants and the area around
the wrist shot as well as I've shared
previously but I digress because another
highly specific feature of Atlantis was
that its Center Island which was
described as being geothermal in nature
in that it was said to have hot springs
as well as Springs of cold fresh water
which is a reason why some have
dismissed the dry Baron Rishad structure
as a possibility for Atlantis
so I imagine that many will find it very
interesting to learn that there is a
little-known study of the Rishad
structure dating back to the late 1990s
which describes the rishat as being a
hydrothermal complex well hot springs
themselves are the very definition of a
hydrothermal anomaly and the fact that
there is an actual scientific study
corroborating this uniquely specific
characteristic is significant in itself
because although the wrist shot may be a
dry Barren place today we must imagine
what a different landscape this region
was some 11 to 12 000 years ago at the
time of Atlantis and speaking of 11 to
12 000 years ago this is the part in the
video where things get crazier and will
continue to do so through the rest of
the video because another key aspect is
that Atlantis was described as having
impressive mountains to the north so
assuming that the Cliffs of the Audra
Highlands don't already meet that
description there is likewise a massive
mountain chain to the north called the
Atlas Mountains which were aptly named
after the first known king of Mauritania
who get this just so happens to share
the same exact name of the very first
king of Atlantis who was also named
Atlas G what's a coincidence but it only
gets more bizarre from here because not
only was the city of Atlantis described
as having Mountains located to the north
but also said to have Rivers so get this
recent scientific Studies have confirmed
an ancient river called The Tom and
reset that flowed from the Atlas
Mountains and winded some 500 kilometers
all the way to the Atlantic Ocean
directly in the path of the eye of the
Sahara and if that isn't fascinating
enough just look at the date of when
that river is known to have existed
eleven thousand seven hundred years ago
precisely within the time frame of when
Atlantis was said to have been destroyed
make no mistake the entire region of the
Sahara looked completely different at
that time compared to what we see today
and the next few details that I'm going
to share may very well blow your mind
because like I've shared in multiple
prior videos there is tremendous
evidence of vast water erosion
throughout the Sahara Desert which is so
extreme that it can be clearly observed
from space via satellite imagery make no
mistake this is not wind erosion and has
been confirmed to be catastrophic levels
of water erosion by subject matter
experts including even the respected
Randall Carlson himself and the
overwhelmingly apparent water striations
that rip right through the rich shot
structure all the way to the Atlantic
Ocean are evident for all who have eyes
to see and upon further study it looks
as if an unimaginably massive force of
water had blasted its way from the
Mediterranean Sea through North Africa
creating a path that just so happens to
be at all the lowest elevational points
through the Sahara just as water would
naturally direct itself
and this is the part where things get
really nuts because there is a little
known yet unbelievably fascinating
scientific study that revealed a
gigantic under ocean seafloor slide off
the coast of Mauritania and is referred
to as the mauritanian slide and dates
back to approximately 11
000 years ago give or take and was get
this believed to have been created by a
tsunami a tsunami that given the very
nature of its shape would have
originated from the East as you can see
from the debris Fields widest point and
pushed Westward to where the debris
field eventually becomes more narrow but
not only that this massive seafloor
slide is located directly in front of
the rishad's path as you can see from
the reference locations on the study
when compared to the respective
locations on planet Earth and when I say
that this seafloor slide is massive
observe the legend in the lower right
from my own estimation it is 300
kilometers or for nearly 200 miles wide
from east to west and nearly 150
kilometers or 100 miles wide when
measured from north to south to put that
East-West measurement into perspective
the debris field generated by this
tsunami is more than 25 percent wider
than the maximum width of Florida's
Peninsula another comparison is that
it's virtually the same distance from
Washington DC to New York City
so the big question becomes what on
Earth happened to send a Biblical sized
tsunami so to speak through North Africa
in the approximate neighborhood of 11
000 years ago and let's be real if the
Rishad structure is indeed the actual
location for the lost city the remains
of it would be found in the area of this
debris field which by the way is stacked
layer of debris sediment and is at least
a couple thousand meters or more than a
mile deep this entire area needs to be
scanned with lidar and even drilled for
examination now let me keep going
because this seafloor slide is not the
only piece of evidence that suggests
that the ocean bulldoze its way through
the Sahara at the time of Atlantis as
the next detail I'm going to share is
extremely significant and I must first
preface it by sharing a highly important
detail that I've mentioned in Prior
videos which is that the last time the
Sahara was said to be under the ocean
was at the time of the trans-saharan and
Seaway which is estimated to have
existed some 56 to 66 million years ago
essentially all the way back to the time
of the dinosaurs and you can distinguish
the regions of the Sahara where this
Seaway is known to have once flowed but
here's the thing you can also clearly
observe that this Seaway is not
annotated to have went West over the
wrist shot rather it went South which is
why I suggest that something else
happened something separate and far more
recently that has somehow eluded
scientists and researchers and here is
the Smoking Gun evidence which proves it
Emmy kousy is the Sahara's largest
volcano reaching a height of 11 300 feet
or more than 3 400 meters and is dated
to be 2 million years old and the last
known lava flow occurred at the south
end of emikusi's Caldera in the
neighborhood of 12 000 years ago give or
take and this is the part that is
unbelievably significant because notice
how the volcano is positioned directly
along the clear path of catastrophic
water erosion just as we see as the
wrist shot you can literally see the
line of the path that the water took and
which clearly eroded and erased portions
of that 12 000 year old lava flow which
means that the flooding would have had
to have happened after that volcanic
activity whether it be 12 000 years ago
or two million years ago at the birth of
this volcano this is hard evidence that
the ocean blasted its way through the
Sahara far more recently than 56 to 66
million years ago that's been claimed
and the evidence does not stop there
there because this white blemish within
emikusi's Caldera at 11 000 plus feet in
elevation is not snow it's salt salt
that is said to be the Reigns of an
ancient Lake that disappeared just
thousands of years ago and not only that
small Aquatic Life including gastropods
which consists of snails slugs limpets
and other small little creatures have
been found within the Caldera and have
been radiocarbon dated to some 14 to 15
000 years ago how did they get there and
where did that salt come from because
make no mistake this salt water would
obviously had to have come after this
volcano's eruption certainly not before
so let me now take you back to the
Rishad structure so I can share one of
the most significant details of this
video as it will prove that seawater was
indeed inside the wrist shot at the
exact time of Atlantis
just as I've shared in other videos all
these white blemishes are indeed salt in
fact the entire region around the wrist
shot in Mauritania itself is known for
vast amounts of salt their mined and
exported to this day and when you
consider that all the areas in and
around the wrist shot with these
concentrations of salt also happen to be
in the areas of the lowest elevation it
seems reasonable to conclude that
seawater had once settled and evaporated
here and this next part is the Smoking
Gun evidence as I have found another
little-known study that shares how
Aquatic Life including mollusks which by
the way examples of mollux include
oysters clams mussels squid and even
octopus existed in the brackish Waters
within the wrist shot and have dates
ranging from 15 000 to 7 700 years ago
which proves that the wrist shot was
consumed with water at the very time of
when Atlantis was said to have been
destroyed 11 600 years ago let that
think in for a moment as the
implications are massive and let me just
say if everything I've shared so far
isn't compelling enough wait until you
hear these next several arguments
first consider that the story of
Atlantis actually originates from the
ancient Egyptians who claimed that they
were colonists and the remaining
survivors of a civilization that was
destroyed in a cataclysm and this is
where the legend of Atlantis comes from
which is something that most people are
not aware of and so when you consider
this next remarkable fact that was only
discovered not long ago is that the
Sahara was a lush green tropical
landscape at the time of Atlantis and
considering that Atlantis was said to be
abundant in exotic fruits and vegetation
and had Lush Hanging Gardens when you
piece together the fact that the Sahara
was a known lush tropical environment at
that time only further adds to these
possible similarities and listen to this
the green Sahara existed up until
approximately 5 000 years ago when it
shifted to the barren desert we know it
for today however some estimates state
that this transition may have happened
as recently as 4 500 years ago which is
a curious time frame as it precisely
coincides with the estimated date for
when the pyramid of Giza were
constructed some 4 500 years ago and
that brings me to another curious
observation which is that the notable
Egyptian eye of Horus is uncannily
similar to the eye of the Sahara when
observed from altitude of course many
will consider this comparison to be a
stretch however it certainly has a
thought-provoking resemblance does it
not but that aside and although the
Sahara Desert initially seems like the
least likely place that you'd find the
lost city of Atlantis it actually makes
a lot of sense when you piece together
other key details for example Atlantis
was said to be busy all day and all
night rich in trade and with people
speaking languages from all over so ask
yourself does it really make sense to
suggest that a city so vastly consisting
of travel and trade would be located in
the middle of a vast dangerous ocean I
mean would other less Advanced seafaring
civilizations venture out to the middle
of the ocean to hit up a local market to
trade for ripe fruit spices and
vegetables or is it far more likely that
based on all the new scientific data
that we have that the region of North
Africa which we now know was connected
by a diverse massive network of rivers
which of course are conducive for travel
wouldn't that be more feasible I mean
after all new studies involving lost
human civilizations of the Sahara have
concluded exactly that and something
else worth mentioning is that Atlantis
was an Empire said to be made up of ten
kingdoms and I would not be surprised if
any of the other nine that made up this
Empire would be found in the island
chains found in this region including
the submerged Islands such as the Azores
I am simply focusing on the capital city
which was said to be made up of
concentric circles and the eye of the
Sahara is the one location that matches
that highly specific characteristic and
nearly a dozen others heck even the
names are still the same now if
everything I've shared so far isn't
compelling enough the next few details
will hit the nail into the coffin that
the eye of the Sahara is by far the most
likely location for the Lost capital
city of Atlantis because many have
argued that since the Rishad structure
is a quote natural formation it could
not possibly be the location since after
all Atlantis was created by the god
Poseidon but when you consider that
Poseidon was the god of the sea water
horses and earthquakes the Greek word
Poseidon itself translates to quote
husband of the Earth or Lord of the
earth it seems to me that this is a Lost
in Translation phrase that is meant to
describe what we call today mother
nature which if you ask me would of
course make the most sense but besides
that we also know that humans have built
upon the most unique natural formation
since the beginning of time and still
due to this day
furthermore people will also say that
Plato stated that Atlantis was located
quote west of the pillars of Hercules
which we now know today as the Strait of
Gibraltar which is why many suggest that
Atlantis would most likely be found in
the middle of the Atlantic Ocean however
Plato did not say West he actually said
in front of and the first thing you
should know is that when you exit the
Strait of Gibraltar the current takes
you directly south towards the wrist
shot but furthermore assuming that a
distant past civilization even had
adequate seafaring vessels that could
survive the open oceans you had
essentially three choices of travel when
leaving the Straits you either follow
the coast to the right follow the coast
to the left or go straight into the
unknown Endless Ocean Horizon at your
own Peril so here is something
interesting to think about if you
traveled along the coast with Africa to
the left you would Journey west
southwest for more than 1200 miles
before rounding Africa's Western Sahara
coastline
to put that distance into perspective
that is equivalent from New York City to
Lincoln Nebraska that is no little trip
I point that out because it's not
unreasonable to say that the Rishad
structure is in front of The Straits
when you travel by boats but regardless
Plato never said West and by the way
another detail people get caught up in
is that Plato stated that Atlantis sank
beneath the waves which is why many have
long assumed that Atlantis would be at
the bottom of the Atlantic Ocean however
Plato also described that the destructed
area of Atlantis following the cataclysm
consisted of reeds of grass and that the
area was no longer navigable by ship as
it was blocked by a barrier of mud well
that does not indicate anything about
being at the bottom of the ocean rather
he is essentially describing reed-filled
salt marshes that are known to exist in
Shallow coastal regions and although the
wrist shot is now some 1200 feet above
sea level we know that that of course
was not always the case considering that
the sea life once existed in the wrist
shot some 11 to 12 000 years ago but
this is why it is worth discussing the
geological phenomenon known as isostatic
response or glacial isostatic adjustment
which describes that when ice melts the
significant reduction in weight causes
the land to lift back up but
subsequently causes land in other areas
to decrease which is the likely
explanation for the sunken Azor Islands
as it's been suggested that the melted
North American ice shelf caused that
land to lift and subsequently caused the
land in the Atlantic Ocean to sink but
if that is indeed the case would that
not potentially have caused North Africa
to lift I don't know but another
enthralling detail that goes along these
lines is to note that the antipode of
the wrist shot structure today and by
the way if you're not familiar an
antipode is a location that is directly
opposite of another location on our
globe so get this the antipode of
Mauritania is Zealand idea a
scientifically confirmed sunken
continent that was only discovered in
2017 and considering that many have
theorized that what happens on one side
of the earth could potentially affect
the location directly on the other side
this detail is worthy of discussion and
by the way let me give a quick shout out
to my great friend Nikki of the Nikki
Anna Jones YouTube podcast channel for
sharing this highly thought-provoking
detail with me definitely go to her
Channel hit the Subscribe Button as she
is completely awesome her personality
and inquisitive mindset are infectious
and I know that you'll just love her now
one last final yet important argument to
be made related to the Rishad Atlantis
theory is that many will say that the
measurements provided by Plato for the
size of the capital city make the wrist
shot far too large however I disagree
and would argue that the true
measurements would surely have been Lost
in Translation over the course of some
12 000 years and through the numerous
changes of language that would have
cursed occurred during the passing of
that prolonged time I mean it's not like
anyone today speaks Latin which was once
a Common Language and heck even the
Modern English language itself is only
500 years old and derives from Old
English which is quite a bit different
and in that in itself is only 1500 years
old make no mistake languages are
constantly changing and keeping up with
measurements I would argue could be a
very difficult challenge especially over
12 000 years and Solon went out of his
way to describe this issue of
interpretation when he stated that he
would Endeavor to the best of his
ability to describe the specifics of
Atlantis and considering that Atlantis
was said to be busy all day and all
night it's fair to say that the local
population would have had to have been
in the millions just as we find in other
bitty busy cities throughout the world
today so the city of Atlantis would have
had to have been large enough to inhabit
a sizable population I mean let's note
that modern metropolitan areas are very
comparable to the size of the rich shot
for example the Paris Metro area is well
over 20 miles from one side to the other
and the same can be said for modern day
Cairo the reality is that Lost in
Translation is a very real thing because
even the ancient Greek word used by
Plato to use and describe the word
island of Atlantis was the word nessos
which when you research the origins of
that word you find that it has five
different translations which include not
just the word Island but Promontory
Peninsula coast and even describes land
within a continent that is surrounded by
lakes rivers or streams which would be a
completely appropriate word to describe
the Rishad structure at that time
when you add all of these details that
I've shared throughout this video
together I'd say that the pomponius Maya
map is probably the least compelling
part as it may just be talking about the
atlas people who lived under the the
Ancient mauritanian King of the same
name at least that's how some will come
to dismiss this but then again it seems
to me that the very name Atlas was
carried down and reused just as people
do with names today all I know is that
the numerous details shared in this
video are too astounding to be ignored
and Atlantis or not whether it ever
existed or whether or not the rift
structure would be the long lost
location if nothing else like I said
earlier the rear shot structure should
be listed on natural wonders of the
world and not only that the very nature
of the Sahara Desert having clear
evidence that the ocean blasted over it
far more recently than 56 to 66 million
years ago should be a topic that is
front and center among researchers
scientists climate scientists and
everybody geologists this is significant
so I know some people will dismiss the
possibility of Atlantis and ridicule the
wrist shot Theory great but like we need
to talk about the science aspect of this
and what the heck happened to the Sahara
Desert now I must share something that I
am incredibly excited about which is
that I will be giving a live
presentation next June in Asheville
North Carolina alongside Legends
including Graham Hancock Randall Carlson
Ben from Uncharted X Johanna James and
nearly a dozen other brilliant
scientists and researchers at the first
annual Cosmic Summit conference created
by George Howard of the cosmic Tusk this
two-day event will discuss the evidence
of the younger driest climate
catastrophe that we believe reset
ancient human civilizations and this
will give you an opportunity to come rub
shoulders with us and take part in
discussing fascinating topics with other
like-minded people however this event
will also be available to be streamed
through howtube I'll include links for
both websites down below but I'm very
excited about this I can't wait for it
I'm going to be giving a very
interesting presentation I have long
desired to give in-person live
presentations it's something I should do
in a prior career so that being said I'm
going to close this up leave a comment
hit the like button and subscribe but my
name is Jimmy corsetti my channel is
called bright insight and stay tuned for
many more videos to come take care
everybody